this past weekend I decided to fly to
Greenland on behalf the United States to
make sure make sure that this deal goes
through and the purchase happens I
brought a camera crew I brought a camera
crew and it's going to be our brand new
cone without porter special Conan in
green
and again I asked this last night of us
again who here has been to Greenland
exactly that's my point nobody goes to
Greenland but they should because they
are lovely people really lovely people
very funny and very cool and they have
an amazingly beautiful country it's just
staggering so I'm very happy that I went
here is just a very short clip from my
visit on my last day I flew north to
illumise at to see the ice cured and
icebergs Greenland is famous for not to
keep obviously oh you like that one you
like that one Wow look at that and
there's a cruise ship everyone on that
cruise ship has diarrhea I don't think
I've seen an iceberg before
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean this is nice but incredible waste
of advertising space we'll take care of
that yeah anyway be sure to tune in to
our Kona and ghrelin special airing next
Tuesday I was able to make Greenland
part of the United States that's gonna
be a lot of fun